the uk will be rolling out covet 19
booster shots in september yep so
they're they're going to be having
and there was a story in nbc that really
freaked me out and
uh i know you guys you don't want to
hear me say it but i say it again
there's a story from nbc that said mix
and match and it said some experts were
advocating for
taking multiple different kinds and i'm
just like stop stop
no no nbc which experts i hate when they
say experts
what are they talking about it was like
uh it was an nbc article
i i gotta pull this one up i gotta pull
so i gotta find this one but that's why
i'm just like
i'm pretty sure if you go to your doctor
and you ask them they're like no
no no no don't do that let me uh let me
see if i can find the story because we
have the one about uk is gonna be
introducing boosters want to know what
benefit there would come from mixing and
matching them do you see any kind of
benefit
chris not i can think of off top my head
so so
so uh not really just uh just to bring
it up this is nbc news
mix and match coveted vaccine approach
boosts immune response study fines
now i will state as far as i can tell
the fda is not approved of that practice
okay there you go but consult your
doctor
yeah some european countries have
started offering alternatives to
astrazeneca and a second shot
after the vaccine was linked to rare
blood clots so uh they
this is nbc news and it's cover it's
it's it's a story by reuters
here's the best part there's no byline
there's no violence this is a major
taboo in journalism
we're launching the newsroom for tim
castle and and i'm very much always like
we must have bylines and bios for all of
our reporters
people need to know who wrote it and
then be able to email that person
with corrections and our corrections
department and we're going to have fact
checkers
when it just says buy reuters like
source
reuters okay i suppose i can maybe take
let me let me see if i can dig deeper
we'll do this in real time let's see if
i can take mix and match kovid
search that and reuters
and uh there we go all right and now
okay so we do have a name we
we find the name now alistair smout mix
and match approach boost immune response
of astrazeneca shot study fines when nbc
news doesn't put a byline on it
makes you wonder like we don't know who
wrote this or why the guardian does this
a lot
staff that's not a credible source when
they do that
if for all you know it's written by a
robot and it's true they they have
robots who write news stories
there was something uh i've talked about
before it's called natural sciences
you've ever heard of this
they have automatic news articles that
publish so what they'll do is
they'll have specific parameters like
temperature
um forecast for weather and then an
article will automatically be generated
saying
the the the the five-day forecast for
you know tallahassee florida is today
will be sunday by tomorrow you can
expect to see clouds
completely automatically generated they
do the same thing with sporting events
mma and football or whatever it'll be
like you know the the raiders scored a
goal in this quarter in that quarter and
did this and they'll show you all the
stats
written by a robot you got to watch out
for those things well well you do and it
was uh the snowden
leaks back in 2013 which so show that
the gchq
had bots that were so good at writing
comments under
under all the major newspapers that
people couldn't detect what was what
so that's been a thing for a long time
trust me things have gotten a lot better
since 2000
stuff in the live chat sometimes where
it will be two comments back to back
that will say
different things in all caps about for
instance me
it'll be like ian's the best ian's the
worst but it'll be at the exact they'll
come at the exact same time two
different accounts all caps and it's
like
so very weird that those could be two
people one of the reasons i i tweeted
before
stop responding to people who don't use
real names and and photos and see your
political discourse improve
one of the reasons i tweeted that it was
it was a subtweet i was tweeting about
you know certain trolls but one of the
one of the main issues is that we've
long known that governments use what's
called sock puppets
they use one person will have 50
accounts
and they'll bombard you with an opinion
to make you think it is public opinion
people fall for this like crazy sure
you'll get a small pizza restaurant
we'll announce they're having a uh you
know like
the the proud boys are going to have a
meeting at some restaurant the
restaurant owner has no idea
and then one day the restaurant owner
gets 40 you know emails or whatever
and they're all from different people in
different names saying why are you
hosting white supremacists and nazis
and they'll be like whoa oh what are all
these things there's probably one person
doing
it that's why it's like i want to know
who i'm talking to
and uh within reason i still will engage
in conversations with people who don't
use
you know names or or photos or anything
like that sometimes people want to be
anonymous for an obvious reason we
talked about this
but i'm just pointing that out that if
we're in this space where we're like
we're not going to stand by our names
and have these conversations
then you have a massive exploit
in your face from activist groups and
i'll tell you one
thing conservatives are not engaging in
this i'm sure some are
but they are not as politically savvy
and organized as
the mainstream left is and the
intelligence agencies
so when it comes to engaging with stock
puppets it is probably two to one that
you're engaging with a leftist sock
puppet who's lying to you then you would
be someone on the right
but it exists on both sides well we know
information is power and so of course
this power has not been left to its own
devices and this isn't
this goes way beyond citizens i remember
there was this really embarrassing
moment i think read it when it you know
was first coming out and it's really
starting to explode i can't remember the
year
i'd have to look it up 2013 to 15
somewhere in there and they said
hey where's our traffic coming from i
think it was on like our data is
beautiful so they looked and they looked
at the ip accounts and oh my gosh
wouldn't you know there's this one
little town in north carolina
that like blew everybody else out of the
water and that's where fort hood's
located and they have an operational
center for information control right and
then and then i think they vpn it and
got rid of that little like data signal
but it was just it was pretty obvious to
me what was happening then
right so information is actually power
so when you see comments you have to
know
first question ought to be is this real
because it might be it might not be we
don't know
we just don't know but information is
power yeah yeah which is why
um when the new york you saw the new
york mayoral election thing happen
eric adams is like yo what's with all
these extra votes yeah
all these liberal journalists come out
saying you're trumpian you're lying
this is ridiculous you're a sore loser
even though he's winning yeah
and then it turns out that the auction
board was like oh actually yeah he was
right
sorry about that but you see the
immediate reaction from the
establishment is
protect the machine at all costs right
don't challenge don't question don't
investigate
when i when i went to do the sweden
investigation
donald trump goes he's at a rally and he
goes did you see what happened last
night in sweden it's terrible
and then uh there they the media
explodes like what happened last night
in sweden trump what are you talking he
was talking about a documentary he
watched on fox news
last night and so he didn't speak as
clearly enough i announced
i didn't go fund me i'm like hey i'm
gonna raise money to go to sweden and
actually investigate because i'd worked
for vice i'd worked for
disney and i had done these kinds of on
the ground
documentary investigations and i had
journalists i knew from vice message me
saying do not go
and i was confused i was like what do
you mean i was like one guy one of the
guys i went to ukraine with
and i'm like you we went to ukraine
together to investigate stuff like why
wouldn't i go to sweden and he goes
just don't do it give the money away
give it a charity and i was like uh
i raised money to go to report
journalism it would be fraudulent if i
gave it away i have to refund it
and then i got another message from
someone saying don't fuel their
conspiracies and i was like
do you think the conspiracies are true
because if i
actually go i'm assuming i'm going to
prove them wrong and they're like no
don't go creepy people i knew and worked
with all of a sudden were just like
do not challenge the machine and that
was just about the machine
it was weird what do you think that was
really about i have no idea
it's it's a cult man and i i i say cult
a lot and people are like
you know tim saying cult again uh when
when
people i worked with advice who are
low-level
reporters and they get paid trash we fly
around reporting stories one day just
instinctively defend the machine
how did no one told them to message me
there's no handler like they're not
secretly part of some government agency
they were just so indoctrinated they
were like don't you dare report on any
of this
because we said no and i'm like i i'm
genuinely confused by what you're
talking about
and i went and then slate these lefties
loved that i came back saying like yeah
there's not really
that much crime it's like so it's it
there are problems here
crime is going up but relative to most
places and and the problems of sweden
were very very nuanced it wasn't like a
bunch of immigrants came in
a year ago and then caused problems
there's actually the children of
immigrants for 20 years ago there's a
lot a lot of nuance there
and sweden really screwed things up but
i was just
to experience that whole thing was a
very strange experience
from having people i knew and worked
with saying do not report
don't do journalism and i'm like but i
always do journals it was like
it's like brain slugs infected their
bodies and took them over it was the
weirdest thing
and then going to sweden experiencing
the message control
when when all of the media aligned
against me after we got into this
conflict in an area called rinkaby
it was weird to see how coordinated the
machine was
creepy has it always been like that or
do you think it's getting worse
i think it's getting worse and and what
could explain that so
so back to this idea of leaders and
followers i have this this theory that
that that things are getting so
tense for people right so so
young people in particular i i've just
had this this event this really nice
young kid
comes up he's in is in teens he's in
college and he's like
thanks for what you do um i have a
question like
what would you do if you're me he's like
i'm studying but i don't believe in the
future at all and he's he's coming up
with
this existential dread which is i'm
supposed to live into this story here's
my story
go to school get good grades uh come out
get a job
you're supposed to plan on all this
stuff meanwhile what's your school
telling you oh hey the ice caps are
melting and this whole thing's about to
go up in flames
you know it's hard to sort of square
that circle and so i think confronted
with that people
start to um cling to anything
including maybe you know obedience to
the machine or something i think it's
just
i think it's a big defense for sure it's
part of why information is so powerful
like what you said earlier because if
you can give them
a path or a reason to live or a solution
or at least an idea of a solution like
yeah
iron fertilization we can repopulate the
salmon have you studied iron
fertilization you yeah they're gonna get
the
you know carbon out of them you can read
blooms or whatever the coral reefs uh
it also feeds the salmon the iron
creates plankton which then the salmon
can eat and so we can regrow the fish
population of earth we can regrow the
coral by shattering it and placing it
all over and then it all grows together
and forms giant wreaths
like there are solutions if people don't
know they get scared and then they look
to
they want a leader and they look to
people like anthony fauci who's like the
tv leaders that pop up
reality tv stars actors you know i i
feel like
people don't want to have any
responsibility they just want to be told
what to do
i don't know i if i know what to do i
like it i like the line set it bro
you don't even get to do anything the
cdc just says do it and you just do it
like okay well you know look within
reason i do respect cdc guidance
i say within reason because you know i
know tuskegee for instance
but uh you have personal responsibility
yes they can give you advice but
ultimately it's on you to go and seek
out what's right for you which includes
talking to your doctor or perhaps
becoming a doctor
well yeah that's true the bright spot
that came for me out of all this covid
stuff
was um really looking into things like
certain supplements and whatnot and real
and realized that i had bought into a
bunch of junk
that my culture had given me including
my doctor literally telling me
vitamins are just an expensive way to
take a leak right
you know you eat them and you piss them
out right but water soluble
vitamin d i have this whole crazy story
on how important vitamin d is
and and it's an amazing story and fauci
said so
well only because jennifer garner asked
him on her v-log
and she was star struck so he did admit
to taking vitamin d but he never came
out and said you should
i thought he did i thought he said
vitamin d is good and people should be
it's still on the nih treatment
guidelines right now
under covet it says there's neither
enough data to to refute or endorse
no wow vitamin d but there's tons of
data
you know what i found um i i like
winters are
you know like i i feel i i don't like
winters i like the cold
and then uh this past year i started
wondering like why why am i like so
energized and energetic and jumpy and
like full of
you know just ready to go why do i skate
better in the summers and in the winter
even indoor it's harder and i'm like
dude it's vitamin d vitamin d i'm not
getting enough sunlight i'm inside it's
air it's it's heated
and there's less sunlight so i i got
some vitamin d gummies and i felt
fantastic yeah i was like i'm not
getting enough before you study vitamin
d it's like it's not a vitamin it's a
hormone it's like involved in all these
things and it's about inflammation and
bone repair it's like crazy good stuff
and almost
everybody is deficient in it
particularly
dark-skinned people because you're the
melon in your skin
particularly at higher latitudes
prevents the sun from coming in the uvb
rays and making the vitamin d so
like if you or i took our shirt off and
you know we'd get like 10 000 units in
like 15 minutes right but
but of course consult your doctor before
taking any vitamin or
taking your shirt off
is there a difference in the value
biochemically of of getting
producing vitamin d naturally from
sunlight or
taking a vitamin d supplement they're
probably well so the vitamin d from
sunlight has its own
regulation process where you can't oh
you can't get too much it'll shut itself
down
if you you could technically take too
much but it's a big big big number
it's a really big number it's a fat
soluble no no it's a hormone
is it yeah it's about soluble yeah yeah
the water soluble stuff you just kind of
piss out but the fat soluble stuff you
can get really sick on
right like vitamin a it takes well
that's a different story but um vitamin
d
takes a lot like you would have to take
mass at my weight for myself
it would be a huge number i i i was
reading about um
like general health and dieting a long
time ago and i read that we don't get
enough vitamin c in our diets
it was something like for every 50
pounds uh an animal weighs they produce
something like a thousand milligrams of
vitamin c or something like that i don't
know if you got numbers
maybe you know it it's true so so we're
one of only three mammals that can't
make vitamin c we had some
weird mutation that that bollocks this
up for us a long time ago
every other animal does it particularly
when they get stressed so a goat that's
like breaks its leg or something that
they've done the studies
will manufacture 60 grams of vitamin c
in the next 24 hours oh that's a lot
that's a huge amount
yeah and by the way you can't take that
much because you can't tolerate it
through your gi tract so that's why they
do high-dose vitamin c now
when somebody's coming in with like
full-blown sepsis multi-organ shut down
they pump the vitamin c and they're in
some amazing how it recovers them what
does vitamin c do like is there a
process by which it's converted into
hydrogen peroxide or something like that
no it's the precursor for pretty much
every stress hormone you're going to
make this is going to help you get
through that stressful process right
cortisol cortisone things like that
it's also really important for collagen
repair and things like that so linus
pauling two-time
nobel prize winner he's getting on in
his years and and so you know
sometimes old guys lose the story or
plot line that's what they tried to say
about this guy but in lateness careers
like vitamin c is the bomb he had all
this data four hundred thousand records
from gis
and noted that when this was all before
computers they had to hand track this
he noted over time that the people who
had the higher vitamin c levels
at check-in when they got their
physicals had much lower levels of heart
disease
so right around that same time though
the drug companies like oh you see
people have the plaques in their
arteries and we look in the plaques we
see cholesterol so let's take
cholesterol down he was like
you got it all wrong bucky that's not
what's happening that cholesterol's
there to try and repair the damage the
damage is
happening before and it's because we
don't have vitamin c so he comes up and
he puts vitamin c and then all of a
sudden they're
showing that they're clearing up
people's um
atherosclerosis within months if they
have adequate cholesterol that's doing
it with the help of the vitamins
and the cholesterol is there to help
repair the damage it's already happening
but you could be wrong
i could be wrong and you should talk to
your doctor that's right no but uh it's
guinea pigs
they don't make vitamin c right i'm not
sure about that one there's some bat and
i forget what the other one is
guinea pigs don't pigeons not make
vitamin c either
not sure about pidgeotto just reading
something a long time ago i read his
book
about that is there any explanation it
was saying that
the um and again i'm not an expert in
this like
10 years ago i read this thing it said
that the amount we're told is our daily
100 percent
is the minimum to avoid scurvy okay and
that
if you look at like you said 60 grams
yeah so what what what do we what do we
take like 60 milligrams
you might take 500 or 1000 milligrams or
something like that but again it depends
how much can actually be absorbed at
that time
so our gut really limits that so if you
get in
in real serious situation good doctors
now will give you that right iv because
you can put a lot
in through iv you can really cram it
good doctors
with good opinions good medicine well
i'll tell you so i work with with these
you know doctors who are figuring all
this stuff out and they've got this
great story around vitamin c which
sounds a lot like
all these other stories we've been
talking about right where there's a
whole medical establishment that really
hates the idea and they try and
pooh-pooh it and they design studies to
fail and these guys are just like look
you know when somebody comes into an icu
with multi-organ failure for sepsis
right they can take the average death
rate from around 50
and knock it down to about eight percent
and they can do it reliably and
repeatedly and if i end up in the icu i
want these
guys treating me period and they're and
they're they're doing intravenous like
vitamin c
that's the first thing they do like even
before they take your first vital sign
they get that drip going right so then
some other doctors say well let's study
that and so they design it so that
they administer it within 24 hours of
showing up and these guys are like no
every minute counts they can prove that
every minute counts
and so these guys set up these these
studies and start it within a day and of
course it has a much
lower um efficacy after that so
what do we what do we say about a system
where people are incentivized
to design a trial to fail what if that
was you or your dad or your mom or
somebody you loved
in that that got enrolled in that i mean
how do we roll with that information
it bothers me i've i've never uh
i don't i don't think i don't think
they're gonna let you die man
you know what i mean i think i think
that maybe sometimes people make bad
calls
sometimes a doctor will use his best
judgment but i don't think there's
anybody like twirling their mustache
maybe maybe at big pharma for sure but
like doctors and hospitals
belief systems are powerful enough that
people do crazy things when their belief
system is challenged
yeah that's that's for sure we talked
about the other day that um
another book i read a long time ago that
around 24 or so is when people's brains
start becoming like fully matured yeah
sort of solidifying their world view
mine was around 40. but that's keep
going but but they say that midlife
crisis happens when the brain
reopens to become oh that's what
happened to me so the the idea is that
if you've survived that long your brain
is telling you
the things you've learned have kept you
alive hold on to them
because if we maintain this we can
survive longer
so what happens then is if you present
evidence that is in
undeniable to somebody whose worldview
is solidified maybe somebody who's 30
their their brain will start panicking
because they're like no no no we can't
accept this
it puts us at risk and so their brain
switches to anger mode
and then they shut down the logical
process centers and go right into how
dare you
yeah and they start ad hominem and they
just go nuts and i'm sure people have
experienced this
have an argument with somebody and then
they just snap and you're like why are
you so
mad whoa well that's how you know you've
touched into a belief system so if you
have an opinion right you say
oh i think uh this is the best baseball
pitcher here's my stats and i come up
with different stats and we you know
trade stats for a while it's all cool
but if you have an opinion about
something
that's fine if you have a belief system
it's the emotions yeah
that was uh that was in dogma chris rock
says that he said something like that
he's like an idea can change but beliefs
those are harder to change and people
die for beliefs
yeah i have a lot of ideas they you know
the joke is uh someone wants
someone once commented on a youtube
video saying tim pool's a milk toast fat
sitter and i'm like hey let's roll with
that one and i used it
it's technically not true because i get
really angry about freedom free speech
civil rights and things like that but
for a lot of things like i got some
ideas
but i don't think like if i'm not an
expert on uh uh uh
you know cancer i'm not gonna tell
people what to do with cancer i have no
idea
you know it was making me think about
like um the scientific community and how
like theories and
and hypotheses are battled amongst like
like in um
quantized inertia for instance is a new
theory by uh mike mccauley he's been
working on it and there's a lot of
pushback because it does away with dark
matter in his theory so the people that
have theorized dark matter
don't want their theories to be lost and
upended because then their creds are
diminished and
so uh actually there's somebody i know
very very well
but well a lot of them retain their
privacy whose father
was a physicist and i i was asking about
string theory and m theory and he
explained that there's a big problem
right now
with at the time this was 10 years ago
so i don't know about physics he was
explaining
there's actually a lot of problems they
can't figure out when it comes to string
theory and m theory that
have many people believing it's probably
not correct but the problem is nobody
wants to give up their life's work
they spent 40 years working on these
theories and the math and you want to
come and tell them now it's all wrong
they can't accept that it's very hard to
do i believe it was the physicist niels
bohr who said
science advances one funeral at a time
that's why so brutal because it's true
yeah it's true
and so when it comes to like this whole
area of this medical stuff we've been
talking about
it's really important to understand that
if somebody's belief system is in the
way of you and your health
you need to detect that and then find
somebody whose belief system maybe is
is more flexible that's why there's a
lot of people who are like
who have messaged me saying you know my
doctor didn't know and i'm like bro
there's other doctors out there
yeah a second opinion is like a normal
thing
so didn't know was okay doesn't want to
know is not okay
right i've had a lot of people message
me say my doctor i gave them the data
i'm giving them papers
and they're like don't give me that
stuff i'm not interested
right i say find a different doctor
that's what you do then right
we had um we were talking we were
talking with somebody i can't remember
but they mentioned
that they had a doctor who told them
some given some political response to
their question and so they said
and they called the different doctor and
said i don't care for the politics just
tell me like here's my age she's my
family
and then the doctor's like here's what
we're going to do here's what makes
sense based on the criteria not the
politics
there's a whole article that just came
out about um doctors who've banded
together who are so scared of the
woke-ness
that these are typically older doctors
you know they've been in practice a
decade or more
um men and women doctors and and what
they're afraid of is that they see these
younger doctors coming in who won't
treat
because somebody has the wrong ideology
right like you know if uh that i think
that person's a skinhead or a republican
or a proud boy yeah i won't treat them
or they won't give them the same quality
of treatment but they're open about it
and so this is really terrifying
right to get to that level because now
we're into the us versus them now you've
started to dehumanize
and that's that's when you know you're
getting pretty far down the path so
let's let's
yeah so so just a quick quick aside in
this
i was speaking at this conference this
really sharp guy comes up afterwards
takes me to the side
asks you know this guy had worked for
several joint chiefs of staff
and um was pretty connected in and said
by the way when you were talking chris
about um
that we were going to attack north korea
this was like i don't know five years
ago i was reading all these signs
and i knew we were about to do that
because i suddenly saw all these
articles come out new york times about
how
prison guards in north korea were like
kicking puppies and like just you know
doing stuff
we were dehumanizing so i watched the
dehumanization happen and so i wrote out
to my
my followers i'm like hey looks like
things are about to heat up with north
korea this guy came up in a couple years
after the fact and said
you have no idea how right you were we
were we had two carrier groups in that
moment and they were all spooled up and
we were ready to go
how did they need how did you know and i
said it was easy new york times was
printing stuff about how
how inhumane the guards were in the
prisons over there you never see and it
came out in four
newspapers at once they need to rally
public support right
let's talk about this dehumanize first
that's what you do thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you